.
BRIAN: I'M IN WELCOME TO ONE
NATION.
I AM BRIAN KILMEADE THANK YOU
FOR SPENDING YOUR DZHOKHAR
TSARNAEV WITH ME WITH A SPREAD
WIDE OPEN THE SHOW LIKE NO OTHER
THAT I'VE DONE BEFORE THE
QUESTION, HERE IT IS.
WHAT YOU DO IF YOUR SERIES OF
WINDS AND RESULTED IN A BUSTED
DRUG INFESTED BORDER?
COPS THROWING DOWN THEIR BADGES
AND QUITTING.
INTEREST RATES ROCKETING UP SO
HIGH ALMOST EVERY HOUSEHOLD IS
FEELING THE PAIN.
THEY'RE ABOUT TO GET CRUSHED BY
THE HOUSING MARKET FOR INFLATION
AT A 40 YEAR HIGH PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO ACTUALLY PAY THEIR
BILLS.
LEGIT FEAR OF UNEMPLOYMENT BEING
A BOOM.
YES, TWO WORDS YOU NEVER HEAR
TOGETHER, A BOOM AND
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THIS ALL HAPPENING WITH THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS JUST SIX WEEKS
AWAY.
YOU CAN ANSWER MY QUESTION AT
HOME, BUT LET ME TELL YOU HOW
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE ANSWERED THIS
QUESTION IN WASHINGTON.
THEY DECIDE IF YOU CANNOT BEAT
THEM, THEY WILL TAKE THEM.
IF YOU CANNOT CREATE THEM, STEAL
THEM.
NO JOKE.
THIS WEEK THE WHITE HOUSE AND
THE DEMOCRATS ACTUALLY WITH A
STRAIGHT FACE PAST THE POLICE
FUNDING BILL AS IF WE DO NOT
REMEMBER WHO THE PARTY WAS THAT
DEFAMED AND DEFUNDED THE POLICE.
>> NOT ONLY DO WE NEED TO
DEFUND, BUT WE NEED TO DISMANTLE
AND START A NEW.
>> TALKING ABOUT THE REDUCTION
OF OUR NYPD BUDGET AND DEFUNDING
A 6 BILLION-DOLLAR NYPD BUDGET.
>> DIVESTED.
I AM FOR DEFUNDING THE POLICE.
>> THEY DECIDED TO DEFEND THE
POLICE BUT THEY DID NOT STOP
THERE FOR THEY DECIDE TO TAKE UP
IMMIGRATION.
BUT STILL CANNOT HELP THEMSELVES
IN PLAYING THE BLAME GAME.
FIX THIS IS WHY THE STUNNED
REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ARE DOING
IS SO SHAMEFUL.
IT IS SO INHUMANE.
WE TRY TO FIX PROBLEM THAT
DECIMATED IMMIGRATION SYSTEM,
THOSE DECIMATED BY THE LAST
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE NOT COMING UP WITH
SOLUTIONS BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
WANT SOLUTIONS AT ALL.
BRIAN: THAT SHE REALLY EXPECT US
TO BELIEVE THAT QUESTION WORKED
ALSO CHANGE HER TUNE ON THE
LOCKDOWN PIN NUMBER THE DEMS
NEVER MET A STATE, TOWN, CITY
THEY DID NOT WANT TO LOCK DOWN.
HER PARENTS THEY DID NOT WANT TO
WALK OUT.
BUT NOW.
>> YOU'RE DEALING WITH THE
SITUATION THE HOSPITALS WERE
BEING OVERRUN IN NEW YORK.
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS WILL BE PUT
IN HALLWAYS.
YOU HAVE TO DO SOMETHING THAT IS
RATHER DRACONIAN.
SOMETIMES WHEN YOU DO DRACONIAN
THINGS, IT DOES HAVE
CONSEQUENCES ON THE ECONOMY, ON
THE SCHOOL CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW THAT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO MAKE IN BALANCE.
>> NOW YOU TELL US.
WE WERE WAITING FOR THAT BALANCE
WE NEVER GOT IT.
I WONDER WHAT LED THEM TO THIS
CONCLUSION TO OPEN UP SCHOOLS.
>> THE PANDEMIC IS OVER.
WE ARE STILL HAVING A PROBLEM
WITH COVID.
WE'RE STILL DOING A LOT OF WORK
ON IT.
IT IS WHAT THE PANDEMIC IS OVER.
IF YOU NOTICE NO ONE'S WEARING
MASKS.
EVERYONE SEEMS TO BE IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE.
>> REALLY QUESTION WHAT THE
PANDEMIC IS OVER?
YOU CASUALLY MENTIONED AND JUST
ROLE IN DETROIT WAS 60 MINUTES
THE MIDDLE OF A SOFTBALL
INTERVIEW?
WHAT ARE THESE DEMOCRATS TO DO?
YOU'VE ALREADY PLAYED YOUR TRUMP
CARD A FEW TIMES ACTUALLY.
YOU'VE ALREADY HAD YOUR DOBBS
CARD ON THE TABLE SINCE JUNE.
WE REALLY THINK VOTERS ARE GOING
TO BUY THE SHAMBOLIC MAKEOVER, A
DEMOCRAT NOT ON THE BALLOT SAID
IT BEST AGAIN AND I WILL READ IT
OUT LOUD.
BILL MAHER SAYS THIS.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM THE
DEMOCRATS IS THEIR WOKE BAGGAGE.
THE DEMOCRATS COULD EASILY WIN
EVERY ELECTION IF THEY DID NOT
DO THE KIND OF THINGS THAT MAKE
PEOPLE GO OH MY GOD, THIS PARTY
HAS NO COMMON SE